citizens of the reject Nation the Avatar
has returned don't really cover Netflix
trailers that often because Netflix and
Amazon their trailer Department company
are notorious for blocking our videos
just a quick heads up right off the bat
that if the footage looks a little bit
oner than usual there's a reason why
just trying to get it public for you all
but I got my Opa ready I am ready to
rock I really did love avatar the Last
Bender for you guys who don't know my
wife and I over at our patreon uh we did
our reaction let and watch along for
both avatar the Last Air bander and
Legend aora So it's a patreon plug I
suppose thank you to all who have
supported us over there and yeah we we
love the show I I wanted her to be in
trailer reaction with me but she's
unfortunately tending to something at
the moment but we will be covering this
one together I have high hopes for it
after what Netflix did with one piece
I'm hoping that they can also deliver
with an adaptation of this being Rock
Solid especially after that horrendous
movie that they put out which we also
did a reaction for on this channel
before we go into that action guys I
want to say thank you for being here
please leave a like on this video also
wanted to say thank you to geuel for
partnering with us consistently for a
day like today where I'm going to be
non-stop editing all day especially cuz
I got a Loki coming up in just a few
hours things like gfuel help me
throughout the day having zero sugar in
it but also keeping me focused attentive
sharp I love these things I shut them
out more than I'm required to for a
reason if you want to get yourself some
select tubs use the code in our
description box and pin comment thank
you to gfel for partnering with us once
again let's do this
guys oo I'm kind of nervous let's
[Music]
go
time time is a funny thing
fire the past
the future
awesome Katara
Saka just going to name people recognize
them mixed up Earth
Kingdom Zuko my
man there's only one way oh damn D they
Himi War oh it's
Suki
yeah always remember who you are I'm so
biased right now not even objectively
Tak
cool man oh is that a
Zula show me Momo we
got there all four
nations we got the music and
[Music]
everything woman we're spending
Valentine's Day watching this even
though it comes out a week after
Valentine's Day we'll try to get
screeners and watching this all right
wow okay that was awesome that was
awesome got to create some Avatar te's I
think that's what we're going to create
what reject naations shop.com is going
to create in 2024 thank you guys by the
way who have all been supporting the
channel in the best way possible by
buying yourself some reject apparel we
got shirts like this one space babies of
the Galaxy we got our Pedro Pascal from
last of us hanging out with baby gr
Child Protection Services we got our who
influences the influencer we got a whole
bunch of te's that we absolutely love
that we are creatively involved with
ourselves and seriously it is my
personal favorite way for the reject
Community to support the channel so
please represent and look good while
doing it let's talk about this trailer
people uh yeah I'm exceptionally biased
in this moment I want to just look at it
from a lens of but I can't you know
whatever I just got to be honest with
you like uh it's just playing purely on
the Nostalgia for it this trailer is
tending to those who really did already
have a rency for avatar The Last
Airbender main thing that I think it
really had to get down and maybe this is
not on the Forefront of everyone's mind
is there was that abysmal film that M9
shamon helmed and while some can say
it's so bad it's good maybe I think it
gets a little bit dull that movie it is
a liveaction taint on the Avatar of The
Last Airbender Universe this had to
really showcase the that they are going
to honor the Animated Series the best
way possible yeah like they really
brought it to life the actors they cast
look pretty apt for the most part you
know some of them not quite as much as
you'd expect but for the most part they
look great I even love the height
difference that they got with a and qara
that's really cool seeing Momo seeing
Opa just being here as a fan of the
series and going oh my God all the
things I love being brought to life in a
way that looks accurate and not just
that but it's also like the tone the
overall Ambiance the the overall tenure
of what the trailer is translating of
not just capturing the visuals
aesthetically but trying to sell us on
the fact that they are going to be
capturing the overall spirit and knowing
what the show is capturing the spirit
you guys know what I'm getting at with
that spirit world ha but capturing the
overall spirit is just as essential if
not way more and now it's about like
saying okay how are they going to bring
all the bending to life you know how are
they going to bring all the action
scenes to life but what they gave us
here so far I think like costume design
wise makeup wise uh casting look and
then of course you know playing the
music and whatnot so far it is like yeah
okay this feels like avatar the Last a
bender I'm curious to see how they're
going to make it their own I know
there's going to be some fans you know
and and was going to be a big part of me
too like I just want you to really stick
very close to the Animated Series but I
also want to see what differences that
they actually do because you know avatar
The Last Airbender is an animated
property where I forget how many
episodes were the the few seasons they
had but they were you know like
22-minute episodes some were a couple
parts uh some were longer but most of
them are just 22-minute episodes oh my
God where's the Cabbage Patch guy
where's the Cabbage man I don't know
what the episode runtime I didn't do any
research on this I wanted to just kind
of come in with fresh eyes uh for
whatever this trailer is ultimately
going to convey to us and I'm very
curious to see how they ultimately
translated I imagine they'll probably do
more of the one piece method where they
combine arcs into one episode where it's
like 45 minutes to hour
long uh but hey you know like they've
done a lot of Goodwill after one piece
and while that's a completely different
animated property it has sold me on I
have faith Netflix knows how to capture
what the fans really want and so I'm
going to take a leap of faith with this
and assume that it's better than the
movie that was produced a few years ago
whilst looking for forward to the other
liveaction movie that's going to be
coming out in a couple years so while
not 1,000% sold on everything right now
only because so for a first trailer I
think they got the job done um let's see
how this ultimately progresses guys what
did you think about the Avatar of the
ler Bender trailer leave your thoughts
down below who is your favorite
character from the show thank you
citizens of the reject Nation I'll talk
with you all
soon
[Music]